So, you know, there's a lot of studies that probably, you know, we think, though, we're
going to take probiotics and we're going to change our gut, and that's really going
to help my gut.
It can be beneficial.
I'm not saying that, but if you think you're going to re-floorize your gut, you think you're
going to build your microbiota by simply taking probiotics, you missed the point.
You build your microbiota and your microbiota changes quite quickly with the foods that you
eat.
You go on a vacation, everybody's probably experienced this and your diet changes, you know, drastically
because you're on a vacation, you can be constipated for two days because your microbiota
is just completely thrown in a loop.
You go home, you get back on your regular diet and it seems to settle down and everything
calms down instantly, your microbiota changes quickly.
So, but it changes due to the foods that you eat.
What is the worst habits that we could get into as Americans because we could go to the
grocery store and get anything we want?
We tend to have a habit of eating the same thing all the time.
And even if it's something good for us, the lack of variety in our diet really affects the
diversity of our microbiota.
There's been plenty of studies that the diversity in our microbiota is based upon the diversity
of different foods in our diet.
So it is a catch-22 for a number of people that have, you know, really damaged, gotten borders.
And they have antibodies to all sorts of different dietary proteins so they're limited to their
diet.
It's a difficult catch-22 to healing those people because if you want to diversify your
microbiota, you have to diversify your food.
So, eat as many different vegetables as possible.
I know we tend to, we eat corn and beans and potatoes every night.
Okay, that's not good, of course, or corn as a grade, but that's not part of the discussion.
You know, if you're not, if you're eating the same thing all the time, that's not really good
for your gut.
So, if you want the healthy, diverse microbiota, you want as diverse a diet as possible, meaning
as many different types of vegetables as possible.
Different meats, different things in your diet, different fruits, not just the same thing
all the time.
And again, I've said this over and over over the years, so, you know, the danger of our grocery
store habits these days is you could go and buy apples any time of the year.
And I'm not saying apples are bad for him to say that, you know, I think we're supposed
to eat things in season and our diets are supposed to rotate and change a lot.
Because I think our microbiota is supposed to change and be diverse and that's how we protect
against things like we talked about earlier, like an H. Polona infection, where you just
have one rogue bacteria that goes wild and causes all sorts of disease.